handshakes and congratulations as
britain and india announced new deals on
defence and green energy as well as
plans to fast-track a free trade
agreement
between prime minister boris johnson
saying he and indian counterpart
narendra modi have committed to trade an
investment worth 14 billion dollars
which will create 11 000 jobs in the uk
a decades-long commitment that will not
only
forge tighter bonds between us but
support your goal and the renderer of
make in india
he's the latest western leader in new
delhi to try to entice india away from
its reliance on moscow by promising to
step up cooperation
johnson said britain would help india
build its own fighter jets and they'd
agreed to work together to meet military
threats from land sea air space and
cyber attacks too
russia is india's biggest military
supplier and indian leaders have refused
to condemn moscow for invading ukraine
while the kremlin faces crippling
sanctions india has increased oil
imports from russia
analyst suggests india is focused closer
to home china has been waging border
aggression against india
and no western leader
has condemned the chinese border
aggression
so india is not willing to take sides in
a conflict in which
india has
no stakes directly modi did though push
for an end to the war
we emphasize the need for an immediate
ceasefire in ukraine and the use of
dialogue and diplomacy for resolving
issues
johnson says he doesn't expect india to
change its position on russia but said
modi has tried to use his influence on
president putin france he's intervened
several times with
with vladimir putin really to ask him
what you know what on earth he thinks
he's doing
and where he thinks this is going
while johnson is walking away from his
india trip with promises of a lucrative
free trade deal his visit didn't go
without a hitch there's been outrage in
some quarters after this photo
opportunity at the british construction
equipment firm jcb owned by a
conservative party donor
just days after jcb bulldozers were seen
flattening properties in a largely
muslim neighborhood
rights groups say the demolitions are
part of a pattern of religious
polarization by modi's hindu nationalist
bjp
amnesty international criticized
johnson's photo op as ignorant saying
that his silence on the incident was
deafening alexi o'brien al jazeera